As we've discussed,
a person who has sentenced to death,
who is raised there,
uh,
appeal their case and lost in the state
courts has gone to the state courts in
post conviction proceedings lost.
They're the last hope for that person
is to file in the United States district
court for wherever they are from a appeal
to the United States Court of Appeals,
uh,
under Federal Habeas Corpus.
Uh,
and as we've talked about,
uh,
the courts have restricted
the availability of Habeas
Corpus Justice Brennan and
had a very wide view that habeas corpus
should be available as long as the
person didn't intentionally a
bypass the state procedures.
Uh,
but soon after that justice Rehnquist
tighten that up a great deal and said,
unless the person complied
with every procedural rule,
uh,
raised the issue at the
right time at trial,
raised the issue on appeal,
gave the same constitutional arguments
there that are now being inserted in
federal court.
The federal court would not look at that.
I want to talk just a little while about
how the federal statute was amended in
1996 to restrict even further a review
of state death penalty cases by federal
courts.
And then talk just a little bit about the
standards of review and the burdens of
proof,
uh,
that courts utilize in
deciding these cases.
Uh,
in 1996,
the Habeas Corpus statute was a minute
and a number of ways and I'm only going
to talk about a couple that
are particularly important.
There are others in the materials that,
that you can look at,
but these are the ones that
really made a huge difference.
First of all,
a one year statute of limitations.
There had never been a statue
of limitations on Habeas
Corpus in the history of
the country.
So you had people who
might've been in prison,
let's say in a non
capital case like Rubin,
Hurricane Carter.
If you've ever seen the movie,
the hurricane,
uh,
he didn't get Habeas Corpus relief
until 20 years into his sentence.
Uh,
many other people often,
uh,
later in the time that they had served
would find lawyers who had worked on
their cases or they'd finally figured
it out themselves in the law library.
Uh,
and they,
uh,
get relief.
Now one year,
uh,
once the case is final on direct appeal,
the person has one year
to file in federal court.
If they go into the state courts in
the state post conviction process,
the time will be held for the
time they're in the state court.
In other words,
if they wait six months and then
file a state post conviction,
uh,
application,
and that's litigated through
the state courts for the next,
say,
two,
three years,
uh,
when that is final,
when the state Supreme Court
has finally ruled on that,
uh,
then the person has six months left.
Uh,
and of course,
if you wait until the last minute,
uh,
you can be in big trouble there.
And lawyers have missed
the statute of limitations.
In fact,
quite a few,
uh,
people have missed the statute of
limitations even in death penalty cases
costing their clients,
uh,
any review whatsoever of the
case by the federal courts.
The one thing important about the federal
courts is that the state court judges,
as we'll be discussing,
uh,
later,
our elected,
uh,
the capital cases are
very controversial cases.
It's often virtually impossible
for a state court judge to be able,
uh,
to stay in office if he or she grants
relief in a death penalty case.
The federal courts,
federal judges are appointed for life.
Uh,
and for a long time,
uh,
before 1996 in reviewing these cases,
a number of federal courts had granted
the writ of Habeas Corpus finding that
they were constitutional violations.
Uh,
Congress tried to change this and
did change this significantly.
Uh,
in 1966,
they amended 28,
United States code 2154 d that's the
paragraph that says what the court can do.
Uh,
when a Habeas Corpus petition
is filed in the court,
examines it,
the court can grant the writ if the
State Court decision was contrary to or
involved an unreasonable application of
clearly established law as determined by
the Supreme Court of the United States.
This is a huge change because before,
when a federal court
ruled on a habeas case,
uh,
it made its ruling based upon what it
viewed to be the correct determination of
constitutional law.
Uh,
if the,
uh,
and,
and it didn't necessarily have to depend
upon the United States Supreme Court
decision,
it may be that there was an issue that
hadn't been decided by the United States
Supreme Court.
Uh,
that those kinds of issues
can no longer be considered a,
because the state court,
uh,
has to have been unreasonable
in its application.
Uh,
so the,
the federal courts no longer decide
where they right or wrong on the
constitutional issue.
Just a pure question of law.
Did they correctly apply the law?
Uh,
but where they unreasonably wrong,
uh,
in,
in applying the law,
um,
the,
the first con,
uh,
first clause here,
the contrary to clause,
the court set of Federal
Habeas Court may grant the red,
uh,
if the state court reached a conclusion,
that was the opposite of
a Supreme Court decision,
uh,
on a question of law.
Uh,
in other words,
the state court decided
a case differently.
Uh,
then the Supreme Court had ruled,
uh,
on,
really the same facts are
indistinguishable facts.
Uh,
the other clause,
uh,
the federal court,
grinding the red,
uh,
under the unreasonable application clause,
is the state court identifies the correct
legal principle of a United States
Supreme Court decision,
uh,
but unreasonably applies that principle,
to the facts of the petitioners case.
Uh,
in other words,
the State Court recognized that the
legal claim is governed by the example of
justice O'Connor gives.
And,
uh,
the Williams case,
Terry Williams,
uh,
out of Virginia,
gives the example of a state court
identifies that this is a claim of
ineffective assistance of counsel,
violation of the right to counsel.
It's governed under the supreme
court's decision in Strickland versus
Washington.
But the court might unreasonably,
the State Court,
uh,
might unreasonably apply Strickland
to the facts of that particular case.
This is probably where the federal courts
have more room in terms of examining a
federal issues.
Sometimes they'll say,
uh,
the United States Supreme Court case
required that all of the relevant factors
be considered and the state court didn't
consider some of the relevant factors
and therefore it was an unreasonable
application of the federal law.
But the mere fact that the federal
court thinks that the state court got it
wrong is not a basis for
granting a habeas relief.
This is very deferential
to the state courts.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
what it means,
is that,
uh,
it's going to be much more difficult.
And,
and Habeas Corpus,
uh,
I,
I mentioned,
uh,
in a previous discussion,
a much harder to get,
almost impossible to get evidentiary
hearings now in federal court.
So the combination of the
federal courts not being able to,
uh,
have evidentiary hearings,
take evidence,
consider that,
make findings,
uh,
instead having to defer to the findings
of the state courts and even deferred to
the legal conclusions
reached by the state courts,
uh,
is greatly going to limit.
And it does limit a federal
habeas corpus review,
but we'll see this language in some
of the cases that we'll be looking at.
Uh,
in the rest of the course,
I want to turn the burdens of proof,
uh,
and talk about,
um,
uh,
the different,
burdens of proof that,
uh,
courts have adopted just because very
often in a case the court will decide,
first of all,
what does the person have to
prove to prevail on the client?
Uh,
and then secondly,
uh,
what is the burden of proof?
Uh,
and then thirdly,
who has the burden of proof,
uh,
because if the burden is very high,
the person who has the burden,
uh,
is going to lose unless they are
able to meet that burden of proof.
So how the courts define a,
these are not things that
are in the constitution.
These are things that the supreme
court decides a in decisions,
uh,
in cases that come before it.
Of course,
everyone is familiar with
beyond a reasonable doubt.
Uh,
in criminal cases,
you have to prove that the person
is guilty beyond a reasonable doubt.
If after hearing all the evidence,
you have some reservations,
some doubt about whether this person
is guilty or whether this fact is true,
then the government
has not met its burden.
The prosecution has the burden of
proof beyond a reasonable doubt.
And the requirement would be in that case,
to a inner,
a verdict of not guilty.
Uh,
so that's,
uh,
that's,
that's our highest standard of burden.
Uh,
in civil cases,
uh,
the burden is preponderance of the
evidence just more likely than not.
If you put the evidence on
a scale and you weighed,
uh,
the scale,
if it's more likely than not,
uh,
it's by a preponderance of the evidence.
Again,
who has the burden of proof?
If the side would the burden of proof,
uh,
let's say the evidence is in equal poise,
a,
you can't say one way or the other.
Uh,
then the side of the
burden of proof loses.
So how you allocate the burden of
proof is going to be very important.
Now in between these two levels,
uh,
is clear and convincing evidence,
that,
uh,
means that the court a reasonable,
substantial and probable,
uh,
that,
the fact that you're
trying to prove occurred.
Uh,
so sometimes the courts will say you have
to prove something by a preponderance
of the evidence.
But in other areas they will say it has
to be proven by a little higher level,
uh,
by clearing,
convincing evidence.
And of course,
reasonable doubt for the most part,
a is limited to cases involving,
uh,
guilt or innocence and the,
and the prosecution's burden there.
Now there's another burden.
It's a little less than this
substantial probability.
Is there a substantial probability that
whatever happened affected the outcome
of the case?
Uh,
that means not enough to
be more likely than not,
but enough to undermine
confidence in the verdict.
Uh,
and we'll see that the court adopted
this substantial probability test and a
couple of areas,
uh,
as part of the question of whether
there's a constitutional violation or not.
Uh,
but again,
as we sort of look on the scale of the,
uh,
these,
these two have degree have to
do with a degree of certainty.
We were very certain,
when we say beyond a reasonable doubt,
we're pretty certain but
a little less certain.
When we say clear and convincing evidence,
we're more likely than not certain.
When we say preponderance,
when we say substantial probability,
we're talking about undermining
our confidence in the outcome,
feeling not totally
comfortable with the outcomes.
So that's a little lower standard.
And then finally probable cause,
which just means probably a,
in other words,
when a police officer goes to
get a warrant to search a house,
they'll say,
here's what we've been told,
here's what we think is in the house.
And the uh,
judge will say,
if it looks like it's probably there,
then the warrant will issue a
and the person can go out and,
and,
and sees the prior conduct,
the search.
And if there is anything there,
seize the property.
Uh,
the same thing for,
uh,
implement Arie hearings after
a person has been arrested.
Uh,
the standard is just,
is there evidence to say that
they probably committed the crime?
A,
it's a very low standard,
uh,
but it means that there is some evidence
indicating that the person committed
the crime or some basis
for conducting a search,
a of a house or of a person or some
basis for issuing an arrest warrant.
Uh,
but that's the lowest,
uh,
of these standards,
of proof of these burdens of proof
that the courts have adopted.
Um,
when we get to appeals,
which many of the cases we'll look
at are going to be cases on appeal.
Uh,
one of the questions to look for in these
cases is what exactly a is the court
reviewing.
Uh,
and they fall into three basic areas
that I want to just discuss for a moment.
Uh,
questions of fact,
uh,
is the court reviewing factual
determinations made by the trial judge?
Uh,
in other words,
a credibility of witnesses,
um,
whether a juror can be fair and impartial.
Uh,
and the Ricky rector case,
uh,
the judge was looking at weather Ricky
rector was mentally competent or not.
And there were expert
testimonies on both sides.
Expert testimony on both sides.
Uh,
the Arkansas Supreme Court said the
evidence is hopelessly in conflict.
So we defer to the trial judge because
the trial judge saw the witnesses,
uh,
made determinations of credibility.
Uh,
and therefore we're going to
defer to the trial judge on that.
Uh,
and there's not much left,
uh,
for the appellate court to decide as
long as the trial judge applied the right
law.
That is the law of competency.
By the same token,
uh,
courts have looked at jury's determination
of whether a person can be fair and
impartial.
The parties are selecting a jury,
a person knows about the case
because of pretrial publicity,
uh,
knows a whole lot about the case.
As it turns out,
the more that person's question,
uh,
and at the end of the time,
the defense lawyer moves to
strike that juror and says,
this person can't be fair and impartial.
Uh,
the Supreme Court has said,
uh,
that's a factual determination.
Uh,
so that will be,
we'll defer.
The appellate court will
defer to the trial judge,
uh,
unless it was clearly erroneous.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
that's going to be a higher standard,
for the,
the person challenging the juror
to overcome in order to win.
On the other hand,
we have just pure questions of law.
Uh,
is the death pony appropriate for
people who are intellectually disabled?
Uh,
that basically involves the question
of pure constitutional question,
uh,
of what the scope of the eighth
amendment is and whether it prevents.
So that's a case that the appellate
court or the Supreme Court of the United
States,
uh,
in this case is going to decide without
much deference to the trial judge or
without any deference to the trial judge
because it's a pure question of law.
Uh,
whether the due process clause requires,
say,
a hearing or requires notice,
uh,
in a particular situation,
this again is going to
be a legal question.
And so an appellate court will decide
that and be pretty much free to apply the,
to decide what the law is and
then apply it to the facts.
Uh,
and then what we often have our
mixed questions of law and fact,
uh,
the question of ineffective assistance
of counsel involves both the law with
regard to what the sixth amendment right
to counsel and guarantees a person.
But it's also intermeshed with the
facts of what did the lawyer do and that
particular case,
why did the lawyer do it and so forth,
which we will talk about more when
we talk about the right to counsel.
But so depending upon which
of these general areas,
the question fits in the appellate court,
uh,
may or may not,
have a,
uh,
a more vigorous,
a role to play,
uh,
almost complete deference
to the trial judge.
If it's,
if it's a factual question,
court's going to be able
to do whatever it wants.
If it's a question of law,
it's going to try to determine
the constitutional law.
Uh,
and then finally,
if it's a mixed question,
the court is going to try to
distill out what are the facts,
which we still defer to the trial judge.
Uh,
but what are the legal questions,
uh,
which the court,
is going to decide
related to this?
Is that what standard,
uh,
does the court apply?
Uh,
in reviewing these various
questions that I have described,
a de Novo review,
uh,
the appellate court decides
examples I gave before,
what the Constitution,
what the statutes,
what the rules are,
and then applies them to
the facts of the case.
Uh,
clearly erroneous.
As I just mentioned.
Uh,
the appellate court is going
to defer to the trial judge,
uh,
with regards say to whether a potential
juror could be fair and impartial.
If the juror,
uh,
it goes back and forth again,
we see this with a question of,
could the juror fairly considered
the death pony of Juror?
May?
Well,
I don't know if I could do it.
I think I could do it.
There's a lot of going back and forth.
Ultimately,
uh,
the judge allows the jury to set
a appellate court looking at that,
if that's claimed to be era is going
to defer to the judgment of the,
uh,
the trial judge unless a,
it was clearly erroneous.
The court feels,
uh,
very and strongly,
that the,
uh,
trial judge,
made an error.
Uh,
finally,
uh,
abuse of discretion standard.
Uh,
this is for the one challenging,
uh,
the,
the appellant who's challenging,
uh,
what a judge said.
This is the hardest to overcome.
Uh,
judges have a great deal of
discretion for all sorts of things.
Like whether to grant
a continuance or not.
One party says,
uh,
we need,
we're not ready.
We need more time.
The judge says,
I'm setting the case for a certain date.
Uh,
almost always,
uh,
that is going to be upheld by,
by an appellate court.
All sorts of other,
uh,
administrative or rulings
that the judges make,
uh,
miscibility of certain evidence is,
is,
is judged by,
uh,
an abusive discretion.
Not Always,
uh,
but sometimes,
but the take home story here is if you're
appealing and the standards abusive
discretion,
it's going to be very
difficult to prevail.
Uh,
it's going to be,
uh,
also difficult and clearly erroneous,
much less so,
uh,
on de Novo Review.
So a lot of times the
argument in a case will be,
uh,
what is the standard of review
for this particular case?
Uh,
because if it's one or the other,
uh,
it may determine how
the outcome of the case.
But then when the question,
what if there is an error,
the court finds that the constitution
was violated in some way,
uh,
but doesn't make a difference.
Uh,
do we?
At one time the rule was that if
there was a constitutional violation,
the case was reversed.
A and the person had a new trial.
Uh,
but today the court's employ a harmless
error standards in order to often
confirm a,
excuse me,
a firm convictions and
affirm death sentences.
Uh,
even though there was era,
uh,
the,
highest standard,
again,
this is our highest
standard of proof here.
Harmless beyond a reasonable doubt.
Chatmon versus California,
the Supreme Court held that
even a violation of the
constitution of the United
States could be harmless
if the court could say,
we are confident beyond a reasonable
doubt that this did not affect the outcome
of the trial.
Of course,
it's very difficult for judges to do this.
They didn't see the witnesses.
Uh,
they didn't sit in the jury box.
so how well a court can
or can't do this is,
is a,
is a matter of debate.
Um,
another standard is the one
that I talked about earlier,
but it's used in a different context here,
whether there's a substantial probability.
I talked about the substantial
probability standard and what it was,
uh,
that the era effected the outcome.
Now hear what we're saying is,
uh,
this applies to violations
of the right to counsel.
Uh,
the lawyer did not perform,
uh,
the lawyer was deficient
and the performance,
but then the court as is there
a substantial probability
that the outcome would
have been different even if the
lawyer had done all the right things.
And if the judges sitting there decide no,
then they'll affirm the case.
Uh,
even though the person,
uh,
as lawyer did not perform adequately,
in representing them,
the same thing is true for the discovery
or the withholding of exculpatory
evidence.
The prosecution has a responsibility
to turn over evidence that shows a
innocence.
Uh,
if the court finds that that's not done,
the question is going to ask is,
is there a substantial probability
that that evidence had,
had been presented to the jury,
would have affected the outcome?
And if the judges can shrug
their shoulders and say,
no,
we don't think it would,
uh,
then they're going to affirm that
conviction even though the prosecution
withheld evidence.
Um,
finally,
uh,
just to mention it,
the,
the other standards applies
to non constitutional error,
uh,
in the federal courts,
which is weather,
uh,
the,
the era,
whatever it was,
had substantial or injures effect,
uh,
on the verdict.
Uh,
this is also a,
the standard that the supreme
court adopted for Habeas Corpus,
uh,
violations that if there's
a habeas corpus violation,
we don't ask,
is it harmless beyond a reasonable doubt?
Uh,
but we ask,
uh,
whether it is a,
substantial,
uh,
or injurious,
impact on the verdict that was decided.
Uh,
one last thing on harmless error.
Some errors are never
harmless structural errors,
uh,
one,
is racial discrimination.
Uh,
if there's underrepresentation of
people of a race or ethnicity or gender,
uh,
in the jury pools,
the question's not going to be did it
make any difference than the trials?
We'll never be able to know that.
One reason why it's automatic reversal
never harmless when jurors are being
struck when they're picking the jury.
Uh,
if it turns out that the
striking is on the basis of race,
then that's going to always
be deemed prejudicial.
And so there's no harmless error,
uh,
applied to that.
Uh,
any kind of a race
discrimination that takes place,
a complete denial of the right to counsel.
This doesn't happen very often,
but there have been cases where
judges have interfered with a lawyer,
uh,
as the ability to
communicate with a client.
Uh,
and in those situations,
uh,
courts have held that that's a
violation of the right to counsel.
Uh,
there's no way to figure out
how much damage it did or not.
So it's never harmless.
It's automatically going to result
in reversal denial of a public trial.
Uh,
not too long ago,
the court,
uh,
reversed a case called Presley versus
Georgia in which the judge during the jury
selection told the people in the audience,
you're going to have
to leave the courtroom,
uh,
while,
were picking the jury because there's
not enough room for everyone in here.
Uh,
the lawyer objected,
raised it on appeal to
the Georgia Supreme Court,
and the United States Supreme Court said,
constitutional violation,
a defendant has a right to a public trial.
And if that right is violated,
the defendant gets a
new trial because again,
it's virtually impossible to
assess what difference it made.
A,
but this is such a basic
and fundamental right,
uh,
that it's going to be
automatic a reversal,
um,
absence of the defendant from the trial.
Uh,
sometimes things go on.
the defendant hasn't been brought over
from the jail or for whatever reason,
uh,
if the defendant's absent
for the Tra from the trial,
uh,
that's going to be a,
that's never going to be harmless,
Sarah.
That's going to require a new trial.
Uh,
if that happened,
uh,
and,
finally,
uh,
denial of,
an impartial judge,
uh,
again,
hard to know whether if a judge
is not fair and impartial,
uh,
the rulings were right or not.
Uh,
but the court had said
this is a basic right,
that,
uh,
that people have a,
and so if there's denial
of an impartial judge,
uh,
that's going to require
a reversal in cases.
So you look first at these errors
to see are they structural areas,
those are going to be easy,
assuming you can prove them,
which,
which is often not easy,
uh,
or are the arrows which are subject
to a harmless Sarah Doctrine.
And if they are,
what's the harmless,
they're a doctrine that applies.
Well,
I know this is a lot of
technical information,
a lot of procedural information,
uh,
but it's critically
important in these cases,
uh,
because weather,
people,
uh,
are prevail on having their death sins
or their conviction set aside a is often
going to depend on procedurally whether
it was properly presented to all the
courts,
the state courts,
the federal courts.
Uh,
it's going to depend on who
has the burden of proof.
Very often it's going to depend very
often on what the burden of proof was.
And even if a constitutional
violation is shown,
they're going to be a
harmless error standards,
uh,
applied,
that are going to
perhaps make it possible,
uh,
for the court to affirm a conviction.
A,
even though there's been
constitutional error,
we'll see all these things coming up,
uh,
in the materials that follow.